[Music]
where there's light there are shadows
which is where these drawings come to
life the man behind the shadows is
Vincent ball he calls them shadow
doodles ideally he works in his office
on a sunny day all it takes is the right
light and some imagination
the thing is to not expect anything so
just look at the shadows and see if
there's a shape that I recognize because
if I want to have a specific idea in
mind in the beginning it doesn't work I
have to be very open-minded very relaxed
it's it's really like playing and
Vincent playing has produced some 400
drawings to date which he posts on
social media his creations have a
following of around 100,000 people on
Instagram his most popular picture is
concerto for piano pillar
FinCEN file is a filmmaker by trade a
profession that often involves patience
and long-term planning but as a man
bursting with ideas
he creates art from all manner of items
this might be interesting to do
something with because I like the
objects I like the color and it's nice
that you can see true a little bit which
might give interesting shadows and the
fact that these doors open might give
interesting possibilities when the Sun
is too weak for shadows Vincent draws
the curtains and sets up his own source
of light to lamps providing different
options for his cartooning creations I'm
always surprised myself what comes out
of these shadows
[Music]
this work is called put some sand in the
wheels the endeavor began in 2016 with
the shadow of a teacup that he
incorporated into a drawing he uploaded
the result elephant ends with tea onto
Facebook and Instagram
the deluge of positive comments took him
by surprise and inspired him to set up a
dedicated project now he prints the
images on postcards and posters and
sells them online
you get very nice reactions for people
who say ah you make me smile everyday
and that that's a nice mission that's a
nice thing to do in life I think the
project is also enabled him to fulfill a
forgotten artistic aspiration when I was
a kid I really wanted to do comics so I
think I'm coming back to my childhood
dream in a way the shadow artist is
always on the lookout for new motifs
often on his own doorstep in the belgian
city of antwerp once he finds a shadow
with potential he gets out his gear a
few sheets of paper and pans this
bicycle is transformed into a basketball
ring and backboard the project is given
ball a new perspective on shadows and
his own imagination
I think being creative has something to
do with keeping in touch with your inner
child's by playing and keeping things
light his quirky cartoons are soon
headed for a larger format in the shape
of a book due out in June a film edition
is also in the works everything else is
lurking in the shadows
[Music]